[موسيقى]
كان ثلاثه ثيران يعيشون في غابه احدهم
ابيض والثاني اسود والثالث احمر وكان معهم
اسد يطبع بلحوم لكنه لا يقدر عليهم
مجتمعين فقال للثور الاسود والاحمر انظرا
وعلما انه لا يلفت النظر الينا في موضعنا
وتحركات الا الثور الابيض فلونه مختلف عنا
وعن جميع الوان اهل الغابه لو تركت ماني
اكله لصفى لنا العيش بعد ذلك وكتم امرنا
فقالا له دونك فكله اكله بنهم لكن دوره
الاكل لا تنتهي ثم قال الاسد للثور الاحمر
لو لوني على لونك فدعني اكل الاسود فيصف
لنا العيش بعد ذلك رد عليه دونك فكله
فاكله ثم بعد ايام قال للثور الاحمر اني
اكلك لا محال رد عليه دعني انادي اولا اذن
له فنادى باعلى صوته الا اني اكلت يوم اكل
الثور الابيض عذرا ايتها الحكم والامثال
لقد اكلت كل ثيران بكل الالوان بعضها اكل
مويا بلهيب النار وبعضها جمد بالصقيع
فاصبح باردا بليلا لا يشعر بشيء وبعضها
انضم الى الاسد نزع عنهم لونهم وكلفهم
بالوشايه على الثيران فما عاد في مزارعنا
الا الابقار لكن ثورا سيولد من رحمها
ليغير قواعد اللعبه فلكل ثور ثوره تخشاها
كل الوحوش الى
العناوين امريكا من راسها الى اساسها تقع
ضحيه اجذوبه قطع الرؤوس
الاسرائيليه مصاص الدماء الاسرائيلي
ميليشياوي متقاعد يستند الى روايات
دينيه رسم طفلا اسرائيليا محروقا محل
الكلب ب نتنياهو مزور
بدائي بيض للاسرائيليين اذهبوا انتم وجيش
فقاتلوا انا في امريكا
قاعدون عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين في غزه
تطالب باقاله نتنياهو
ومحاكمته اخوه الطفل الشهيد محمد الدره
يلتحقون به بعد استهدافهم بقصف
اسرائيلي سيناء مصريه وغزه فلسطينيه هذه
هي الجغرافيا وهذا هو
التاريخ هل سيفتح حزب الله جبهه جديده على
اسرائيل من جنوب
لبنان الاحتلال يقتل مراسل رويترز بلبنان
ويجرح طاقم الجزيره وزملاء
اخرين عباس يصرح ثم يتراجع افعال حماس لا
تمثل الشعب
الفلسطيني ماكدونالدز تطعم جيش اسرائيل
مجانا فتاكل الضرب في الدول
الاسلاميه نائب لبناني متطرف يدعو الى عدم
التعاطف مع اطفال
فلسطين فنان المقاومه علي نسمان في المشهد
الاخير سنلتقي في القدس او في الجنه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا وشكرا من شهداء المستشفى الاهلي
المعمدانيه في غزه وضحاياها وشكرا من
اطفال فلسطين لغرب الحريه التي تغرب قبل
ان تشرق على ديارنا شكرا لبيض وبيته ووجهه
الابيضين دائما مع اسرائيل شكرا لبوتين
الذي يحترف التحليل السياسي في محرقه غزه
شكرا لاوروبا بائعه ما لا تملك لمن لا
يستحق اما الشكر الكبير فجام الدول
العربيه ومنظمه التعاون الاسلاميه لقد
احرجتم بفعت اخجلتم بشمت اذهلت مونا بدفاع
ابكيت مونا بحما ورفعتم رؤوسنا
بشجاعتهم من لديه مرجعيه مثلكم فلينم
هانئا وباب البيت مفتوح او لينم بباء خارج
الدار قد يكون اكثر امنا لان الديار الان
تكسر فوق رؤوس اطفال غزه وعنهم نجدد الشكر
والتحيه
[موسيقى]
والسلام الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين يعني حمزه يا جماعه الخير ايش ذنبه
حمزه حمزه لقيت هو الناجي الوحيد من كل
عيلته امه وابوه استشهد يعني حمزه بس هو
الناج الوحيد من كل
علم هذا بنك هداف الاحتلال ذات يوم قال
جوزيف جوبلز وزير الاعلام النازي اكذب ثم
اكذب حتى يصدقك الناس فيما اعتبر فضيحه
للبيت الابيض زعم الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه قطعت رؤوس
اطفال
اسرائيليين ولان الزمن زمن تطور تكنولوجي
ورقمي يصعب معه اخفاء الحقائق ودس
الاكاذيب فقد اضطر البيت الابيض الى
التراجع عن تصريحات سيده امام الجاليه
اليهوديه في امريكا وقف الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ليلقي خطاب الدعم لاسرائيل
خطاب تضمن معلومات
مضلله لم افكر حقا انني سارى وساتا كد من
صور الارهابيين يذبحون
اطفال فالرجل تبنى روايه اسرائيليه عن
اطفال قطعت رؤوسهم على يد عناصر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لكن تصريحات المتحدث باسم
البيت الابيض جاءت لتنفي صحه وجود دليل
على ما قيل في خطاب بيد فلا صور وجدت ولا
اطفال قطعت رؤوسهم المستوى الحكومي في
الولايات المتحده علق ايضا بالقول ليست
مهمتنا التحقق من صور اطفال قتلى نشرتها
اسرائيل وهل مهمه البيت الابيض ان يحدث
بكل ما سمع يقول رسول الله محمد صلى الله
عليه عل وسلم كفى بالمرء كذبا ان يحدث بكل
ما سمع انا متاكد من انكم تظهرون على
جماهيركم صور لاطفال قطعت
رؤوسهم ارهابيين حماس والعمل الوحشيه
الاخذ التي
ارتكبوها حقيقه السيد جون بولتن دعني اقول
لك ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن والذي اكد
انه راى الصور وتاكد منها لم يشارك هذه
الصور معنا بايدن لم يشذ عن عن تقاليد
البيت الابيض في قلب الحقائق خصوصا عندما
يريد التمهيد لغزوات
يعلق مؤرخ عربي ففي عام
1945 ضلل الرئيس الامريكي هاري ترومان
شعبه بالاعلان عن اول قصف نووي في التاريخ
على قاعده عسكريه يابانيه كبيره في مدينه
هيروشيما لكن الواقع ان المدينه لم تكن
تحوي سوى وحده عسكريه صغيره وان اكثر
ضحايا القصف كانوا من المدنيين بعدد قارب
ال
100 الفا وفي عام
1964 كذب الرئيس الامريكي جونسون على شعبه
فيما عرف بحادثه تونك ليبرر احتلال فيتنام
لتنتهي تلك الحرب بعشرات الالاف من القتلى
في صفوف الجيش
الامريكي كما كذب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
كولين باول عام 2003 امام مجلس الامن
الدولي ليبرر احتلال العراق بزعم امتلاكه
اسلحه الدمار الشامل المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه يسحب بدوره تصريحات
بايدن ويحاول تغيير وجهه الحوار ليعترف في
النهايه بقتل اسرائيل المدنيين والاطفال
في غزه سيد ممويل الرئيس ق شاهد صورا لق ع
رؤوس الاطفال انا لم اشاهد ذلك ولا اعتقد
ان احدا شاهد ذلك انت شاهدت ذلك لا انا لا
اقول ذلك ام انا اقول ان منذ
اسبوع لدينا كل الدلائل والمعلومات ان
حركت ماس دخلوا اسرائيل وقتلوا المدنيين
هل نحن نتفق على ذلك ام لا هل تعتقد بان
من تقتلهم اسرائيل اليوم في القطاع كلهم
عسكريين
سيد صمويل لا لا نقل ذلك لا نق ذلك لدينا
قلق شديد بالنسبه كل المدنيين بعد فشل
كذبه مكتب نتنياهو بشان الرؤوس المقطوعه
حاول بغباء مستخدما الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
كشف بدوره فبركه صوره طفل محروق قالوا
انها لطفل اسرائيلي احرقته حماس ليتبين ان
الصوره الاصليه هي صوره الكلب نتنياهو
حاول تزوي
ثمت كذبه تحتاج صوره فلن اخترعها هذا كلب
مريض في عياده طب بيطري بتدخل ذكاء
الاصطناعي مثلما بين خبراء صار صوره جسم
صغير متفحم لطفل اسرائيلي مزعوم ونشرها
نتنياهو الاعلامي الامريكي جاكسون هنكل
اول من كشف التزييف هذه الطفله هذه ايش
سوت فيهم حتى انت يا يا مورن الاعلامي
البريطاني بيرس مورن ركب الموجه المدشه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه فاحرجته بل افحمته
بالحجه والمنطق الصحفيه والكاتبه
جريس
say you there man who's got his there
comes in ki out of hiss him in the kills
his family says you're not coming out
all his neb say oh yeah right to keep in
there ignore the situation the man comes
up bu out says you know i'm going to get
rid all this bur the house down lots of
people die and then the only way you
look at
sit الحرب على الارب في
غذه
انها حرب على الفلسطينيين يصادق عليها قطع
تلبيب الماء والكهرباء والغذاء والدواء عن
الاطفال والنساء هذا الكلام لم يقله ابو
عبيده بل قاله دانييل ليفي مفاوض سلام
اسرائيلي
سابق
لقد بلغ الاستخفاف بالعقول والاستهانه
بالنفس البشريه مستويات غير مسبوقه مع
لجوء الدعايه الاسرائيليه والمتبنون لها
من مسؤولين ومشاهير حول العالم الى تزوير
الحقائق واستخدام صور وافلام لجرائم لم
تحدث للاسرائيليين وينسب بها اليهم
والمصيبه الاعظم ان هذه الصور التي
استخدموها غشا ومكرا انما هي صور لمجازر
ارتكبتها اسرائيل بحق العائلات الفلسطينيه
غير الامنه في بيوتها من قصف جيش الاحتلال
ومجازره المفتوحه في المقابل نشرت كتائب
القسام فيديو لجنودها في مستوطنه حوليت
وتعاملهم مع اطفال المستوطن
الذين هربوا وتركوا اولادهم خلفهم وردا
على الاتهامات بشان قيام كتائب القسام
بقطع رؤوس الاطفال خلال معارك طوفان
الاقصى داخل المستوطنات نشرت كتائب القسام
مقطع فيديو يظهر تعامل مقاتلي القسام مع
اطفال المستوطنات مؤكده ان المشاهد صورت
في اليوم الاول لعمليه طوافان
الاقصى انظروا الرحمه في قلوبنا هم
الاطفال لم نق كما تفعلون درينك يلا سي
بسم الله بسم الله يلا درينك في مقابل
فوتوشوب اسرائيل تقارير موثقه من الامم
المتحده وليس من مكتب اسماعيل هنيه تحصي
الاف الاطفال القتلى والجرحى والمحروق
والمعتقلين في موسوعه الجرائم
الاسرائيليه حالفهم الحظ
من الغارات العشوائيه لكنهم بداوا رحله
بحث عن ما فقدوه بين الركام او ربما
يكونون ضحيه لغارات جديده فقصت لم تنتهي
بعد
2230 طفلا فلسطينيا قتلتهم اسرائيل منذ
استشهاد الطفل محمد الدره ابان انتفاضه
الاقصى عام 2000 فتاريخ اسرائيل لا يزال
يتلطخ بالمزيد من دماء هؤلاء اطفال سواء
في غزه او في الضفه
الغربيه ليس بفوت البنادق وحدها يطارد
الطفل الفلسطيني فجدران السجون تروي قصص
انتهاكات بحق اكثر من 160 طفلا اعتقلتهم
قوات الاحتلال بذرائع مختلفه اخبرونا كيف
لشعب ان يكون مجرما وهو يحرص على حياه
الطيور والحيوانات الاليفه حرصه على حياته
طفل غزي مع عائلته من القصف الاسرائيلي
على المنزل لكنه لم ينسى عصفوره طفل اخر
يحتضن قطته نشرت صورته الكاتبه احلام
مستغني مع تعليق اين انت ماض بقط ك يا
ابني لبيت لك بعد الان لكن عل وعسى
فالراحلون يرحمهم
الرحمن القلب الرحيم ليس حكرا في غزه على
الاطفال فهذا المسن لا يترك قطته بدون
معيل حتى لو استشهد تحت القصف اذا بتقرر
بانك انت تطلع مع اهلا
وسهلا في عندي شويه بس وشويه حمام وشويه
دجاج وانا قاعد هنا حتى لو متت ما هي فر
عن المهم انه هذول فيمان وارواح طب كيف
صمدت وسط كل هال الغارات هذ ماطلعت بالمره
كل الدنيا طلعت يا
الهي
لا اعتقد ان افاد القوات الامريكيه للقتال
في الشرق الاوسط ضروري اذ سنقدم لاسرائيل
ما تحتاجه من دعم لكن دون ارسال اي قوات
للقتال هناك بايدن يقول للاسرائيليين
اذهبوا انتم وجيش فقاتلوا ان في امريكا
قاعدون نقدم كل الدعم اللازم لاسرائيل لكن
لننا لا نقاتل معها والجنرال الاسرائيلي
المتقاعد المرعوب اسحاق بريك يدعو اسرائيل
الى اخذ بريك استراحه من الحروب فجن يحبون
التلفونات اكثر من البنادق وبالعبره
المبلطه الخماع جربانين الجماعه خربانين
يكاد
يقولل
نا فارات الانذار الاسرائيليه تصبح
اسرائيل سكانيا تحت الارض من كبيرها الى
صغيرها ومع ضيوفها الكاميرات سجلت لحظه
هروب الرئيس الاسرائيلي ورئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه الى احد الملاجئ بعد انطلاق
صافرات الانذار في تل
ابيب
كذلك اجبرت رشقات صاروخيه للمقاومه اكمال
اجتماع نتنياهو بضيفه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن في الملاجئ مرتين
فيما تم اخلاء الكنيست من اعضائه
المجتمعين لنفس
الاسباب
في المقابل يقول مدير المستشفى الكويتي في
غزه بعد الانذار الاسرائيلي بقصف المشفى
وتدميره على رؤوس المرضى اننا لن نغادر
واجبنا الانساني الا الى الجنه الان
وصلتنا رساله باخلاء المستشفى خلال ساعتين
والا سيخف فوق رؤوسنا المستشفى مل لعشرات
المرضى هناك اكثر من 60 موظف من الطاقم
الطبي لن نستقبل في المستشفى واقسم بالله
العظيم اي عسكري كل من وصلنا الى المستشفى
هم مدني عزا وقرارنا في المستشفى لن نغادر
المستشفى باذن الله تعالى بدانا هذه
المعركه ولن نعود باذن الله تعالى الا الى
ارضنا منتصرين او الى جنه شهداء بينما
كانت كتائب القسام تعلن لاول مره عن عدد
الاسرى الاسرائيليين في غزه والذي يتراوح
بين 200
و250 ومن يعرف الرقم الحقيقي من وزراء
اسرائيل ربما يحصل على هديه صوره لجندي
اسير في هذا الوقت كانت عائلات هؤلاء
الاسرى تلعن نتنياهو وتطالب باقالته من
الحياه السياسيه وتناشد المسؤولين بتفريغ
المعتقلات من الاسرى الفلسطينيين اذا كان
ذلك يعيد لهم ابنائهم وجنودهم الاسرى
تظاهر عشرات الاسرائيليين امام مقر وزاره
الدفاع في تل ابيب للمطالبه باقاله رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
والافراج عن الاسرى في غزه وكانت كتائب
القسام قد اعلنت عن مقتل تسعه اسرى من
المحتجزين لديها في قطاع غزه بينهم اربعه
اجانب ليرتفع عدد القتلى من الاسرى
الاسرائيليين الى 26 كما اكدت وسائل اعلام
تابعه لحركه حماس ان هناك خطر على على
حياه عدد كبير من الجرحى بسبب استمرار
القصف
العنيف مصاص الماء شخصيه اسطوريه تتغذى
على الدم ويرتدي صاحبها الكفن في فلسطين
عثر على الشخصيه الحقيقيه لمصاص الدماء
مسن اشمط يرتدي بدله عسكريه ويدمن الدم
الفلسطيني انه عزر يا خين كاتب اسرائيلي
وعضو سابق في الجماعات الصهيونيه يدعو
لقتل العرب بدءا من اطفالهم الرضع ويربط
كل دعواته بروايات دينيه
شهم شل ده
شل
ي
في المقابل يهود من سكان نيويورك يتظاهرون
رفضا لحرب الاباده الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غز
ويهتفون جرائم اسرائيل في فلسطين لا ترتكب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
باسمائنا والد محمد الدره الطفل الذي
استشهد في مجزره ل قبل 23 عاما يقف الان
ليودع من جديد اخوه محمد شهداء العدوان
الاسرائيلي
الراهن
[موسيقى]
السلام
كرمه للايس كريم البوضه التي يعشقها جو
بايدن ويستبشر الصغار بقدوم ثلاجاتها الى
حاراته هل يتحرك رئيس امريكا لانقاذ صوره
معشوقته من تحول سيارات ثلاجاتها الى
حافظات للجثث في غزه ثلاجات المواد
الغذائيه والايس كريم من مصانع الايس كريم
لكي تستوعب هذه
الاعداد هناك اعداد كبيره من الجثث متكدس
المستشفى مستوطنه اسرائيليه كانت ضمن
المشاركين في حفله غلاف غزه الشهيره تفاجئ
الاعلام العبريه بحديثها عن لطف معامله
جنود المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولا تستبعدوا ان
يكون مستوطنون قد قتلوا بنيران اسرائيليه
م
ز
من يتحمل المسؤوليه اليا وغير المباشره في
جريمه كراهيه من الدرجه الاولى ارتكبها
رجل او وحش امريكي سبعيني بحق طفل فلسطيني
طعنه بسكين حتى الموت وحاول ايضا قتل امه
طفل في السادسه من العمر يقتل ب 26 طعنه
في ولايه الينوي الامريكيه في هجوم معاد
لمسلمين ربطته الشرطه بالحرب الدائره بين
اسرائيل وحركه حماس في قطاع غزه اصيبت
والده الطفل باكثر من 12 طعنه في جسده
وتوجد حاليا في المستشفى لكن حالتها
مستقره الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن من جانبه
صرح انه شعر بالصدمه والاشمئزاز لسماع خبر
القتل الوحشي لطفل في السادسه من
عمره
توجهنا في هذه الحلقه للابتعاد قدر
الامكان عن صور الماسي الانسانيه في غزه
وحكاياتها لكن مجزره يليق ارتكابها بجيش
الاحتلال نتوقف عندها فبعد البيانات
الاسرائيليه التي طالبت سكان غزه بمغادره
بيوتهم والتوجه جنوبا اتقاء لتدمير
منازلهم فوق
رؤوسهم صدق القله الخ
وتوجهوا بقافله الى جنوب القطاع لكن
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه كانت بانتظارهم
لاضافه مجزره جديده الى سجلات اسرائيل
السوداء اذا في الوقت الذي تحدثت فيه بعض
التقارير عن تجهيز منازل فارغه في منطقه
رفح المصريه ابلغت اسرائيل الامم المتحده
بوجوب اجلاء اكثر من مليون شخص من سكان
غزه من شمال القطاع الى جنوبه منشورات
بيضاء تلقى من الجو على السكان غزه اصبحت
ساحه معركه بحسب تحذير الجيش الاسرائيلي
من اجل امنكم وسلامتكم عليكم الا تعودوا
الى بيوتكم حتى اشعار اخر من قبل جيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يجب اخلاء الملاجئ
العامه والمعروفه في مدينه غزه ومن يقترب
من الجدار العازل يعرض نفسه للموت بحسب
منشور الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي ضم رسما
للقطاع واسهم تشير الى الجنوب في دعوه
لسكان شمال غزه للتوجه جنوبا الدعايه
الاسرائيليه لا تهدا لتسويق مشروع تهجير
الفلسطينيين من ارضهم في غزه الى صحراء
سيناء المصريه يتكلمون عن بلدين لا يملكان
شيئا من الحق بهما فهل يقبل الالمان مثلا
بحديث ولو افتراضيا عن رغبه روسيه بتهجير
الى فرنسا وهل ان فرنسا وطن بديل
للالمان there is a huge expense almost
endless space in the sinai desert just
on the other side of gaza can
but at this
point making can can go to egypt bombing
them you you to save them can't come in
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يعتبر ان احتلال
اسرائيل قطاع غزه مره اخرى سيشكل خطا
فادحا لاحظوا كيف يتحول هنا رئيس اكبر
دوله الى مجرد خبير
استراتيجي اعتقد ان الاجتياح البري
الاسرائيلي لقطاع غزه سيكون خطا جسيم ما
يحدث في غزه في رايي هو ان العناصر
المتطرفه لا تمثل كل شعب الفلسطيني
وبالتالي سيكون من الخطا ان تحتل اسرائيل
غزه مره اخرى الرد المصري الرسمي المعلن
على دعوه اسرائيل الى نزوح الفلسطينيين
الى سيناء تولاه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
الذي حذر من التهجير لان فيه تصفيه للقضيه
الفلسطينيه احنا لم نسبب مشكله لحد بل
بالعكس احنا بنتكلم
وعندنا 9
مليون من الضيوف انا زي ما بقول من دول
كتير قوي جم هنا مصر عشان الامن والامان
والسلم
والسلام لكن بالنسبه
للقطاع انا بقول ان الخطوره
هناك خطوره كبيره قوي لانها تعني تصفيه
القضيه ديت القضيه دي قضيه قضيه القضايا
قضيه العرب كلها ومهم ان شعبها
يفضل
صامد ومتواجد على ارضه اما على الجانب
الفلسطيني فقد حسم رئيس حركه حماس اسماعيل
هنيه الموقف بانهم يرون بانهم سائرون نحو
القدس وليس باتجاه سيناء اهل
غزه متجذرون في
ارضهم متمسكون
بوطنهم لن خرجوا من غزه لن
يهاجروا مهما فعلتم ايها القتله ايها
المجرمون ليس لنا الا خط واحد هو العوده
الى ارضنا الى ديارنا الى ارض ابائنا
واجدادنا هذا اصبح ليس بعيد المنال بل
قريب المنال هل سيفتح حزب الله جبهه جديده
على اسرائيل من جنوب لبنان افادت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اصدر امرا بالاستعداد لاخلاء البلدات
القريبه من الحدود مع لبنان وطلب من
الاسرائيليين دخول المناطق المحصنه فيما
اعلنت قوه الطوارئ الدوليه المؤقته في
لبنان انها تتواصل مع الاطراف المعنيه
لاحتواء الموقف وتجنب التصعيد في المنطقه
فهل يعني ذلك فتح جبهه لبنان من قبل حزب
الله حزب الله كان قد اعلن انه على اتصال
مباشر مع قياده الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المنضوي في هذه المعركه العسكريه ضد
اسرائيل ومن معروف ان حزب الله وهذه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه يشكلون مجموعات مسلحه
قويه مدعومه من ايران ويعملون ضمن
استراتيجيه وحده الساحات ضمن ما يسمى
بمحور المقاومه لكن مصادر مقربه من حزب
الله قالت ان الحزب اراد ان يوصل رساله
واضحه ولكن محدوده الى الجانب الاسرائيلي
لذلك حتى الساعه لم يتم خرق ما يسمى
بقواعد الاشتباك المعمول بها عند الجبهه
اللبنانيه اللواء فايز الدويري يجيب على
سؤال هل ستشارك ايران وحزب الله في الحرب
بان الغزوه الاسرائيليه لغزه يعني لزاما
على حزب الله فتحه جبهه لبنان كي لا يوضع
على مائده اسرائيل مستفرد بعد حماس لا
يوجد هناك نفي بالمطلق ولا يوجد تاكيد
بالمطلق ولكن هناك كان تصريح اخر مقابل
اعتقد مندوب ايران في هذ الامم المتحده
عندما قال ايران لن تتدخل عسكريا الا في
حال قصف ايران او تهديد مصالح ايران الان
لنضع خط احمر تحت مصالح ايران هذه تبقى
جمله ضبابيه يمكن تفسيرها من كل شخص
باتجاه معين لكن اذا ما ابتدات الحرب
وكانت تهدف الى تحقيق ما يتحدث به
السياسيين الاسرائيليين اعتقد انه لزاما
على حزب الله ان يتدخل لانه اذا لم يتدخل
بناء على التداعيات سيقول اكلت يوم اكل
الث الابيض اسرائيل تقدم خدمات اجراميه
كامله في نقضها للقوانين الدوليه من قصف
المنازل والمدارس والمساجد والكنائس
واستهداف المستشفيات واخرها المستشفى
الاهلي المعمداني بالاضافه الى سيارات
الاسعاف وصولا الى الطواقم الصحفيه وهكذا
وعلى مرا من المجتمع الدولي المتلون تقتل
مراسلا لشبكه رز في جنوب لبنان هو عصام
عبد الله وتجرح عددا من الاعلاميين بينهم
الزميلان في الجزيره كارمن جوخدار واالي
براخا القصف الاسرائيلي لسيارات الصحفيين
لم يكن صدفه ابدا بل هو استهداف عن سابق
اصرار وترصد جميع الصحفيين تجمعوا في هذه
النقطه في محاوله منهم لتامين ما يعرف
بالحمايه من خلال التج تجمع والتعاضد
بمعنى ان تكون كل اطراف الصراع في اي مكان
على درايه بان هذه النقطه او اي نقطه هي
تقوم فرق التغطيه الصحفيه بالعمل من تلك
النقطه لذلك ينبغي الاشاره وبشكل حاسم بان
الاستهداف في هذه النقطه كان استهدافا
متعمدا لمجموعه من الصحفيين هم بعيدين كل
البعد عن اي ميدان
للمواجهه المحلل السياسي
فلاديمير بوتين رئيس روسيا يضعنا في صوره
ما يجري في
فلسطين واجهت اسرائيل هجوما غير مسبوق لم
يحدث في التاريخ ليس فقط من حيث النطاق بل
ايضا من حيث طبيعه تنفيذه بقسوه ماذا يمكن
القول هنا يجب ان نسمي الاشياء باسمائها
الحقيقيه وترد اسرائيل على نطاق واسع و
باساليب قاسيه ايضا بطبيعه الحال نفهم
منطق الاحداث ولكن لكن على الرغم من
التشدد من الجانبين اعتقد انه من الضروري
التفكير في المدنيين ديمتري ماد فيداب
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ينتقد صمت
الغرب عن المشروع الاسرائيلي لتهجير
فلسطيني غزه لا تستغرب رفيق ديمتري فالغرب
صمت ايضا عن تهجير شعب سوريا من وطنه امس
واليوم واذا مش بكره اللي بعده
اكيد الله اكبر كبر الحرب الروسي نفذ
ط الله
اكبر لطيف طيران الاحتلال الروسي يشن
غارات مزدوجه على اطراف مدينه
ادلب المسيرات المؤيده لحريه فلسطين عمه
العالم نكتفي منها بمسيره لندن الحاشده
التي حذرت منها وزيره الداخليه البريطانيه
ومنعت الهتاف لفلسطين ورفع علمها وتاييد
مقاومتها تحت طائله العقوبات لكن المسيره
انطلقت وفعلت كل الممنوعات الفاضله فهل
تتسع سجون لندن لكل هذه الحشود المتنوعه
عرقيا
ودينيا
[موسيقى]
هاجم البعض بشده الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس وانتقدوا صمته العميق لكن في ذلك
تجنيه على ابي مازن الذي نطق فقال ان
افعال حماس لا تمثل الشعب الفلسطيني
تصريحات اطرت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه للتراجع
عنها حيث ان الرئاسه الفلسطينيه تتراجع عن
تصريح الرئيس محمود عباس الذي قال فيه ان
سياسات وافعال حماس لا تمثل الشعب
الفلسطيني الكاتب المصري عماد الدين اديب
يعول على دوله قطر لانجاز اتفاق بين
الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين في دول اساسيه في المنطقه
ان تعاونت مع بعضها البعض ونسقت مواقفها
اللي هي مصر الاردن الامارات المملكه
العربيه السعوديه قطر وحط تحت قطر دي اربع
سطور وانا لست يعني من انت عارف لست من
اصدقاء دوله قطر بس قطر هي الطرف الذي
يمتلك خطوط اتصال مع كافه الاطراف بعلاقات
جيده ولها خبره في الوساطه وخبره في انجاز
الاتفاقات في القنوات
الخلفيه شبكه المطاعم الامريكيه
ماكدونالدز تفخر بانها تقدم وجبات مجانيه
لجيش الاحتلال اسرائيلي دعما له في حرب
الاباده العرقيه بغزه فتنطلق حمله مقاطعه
شعبيه واسعه ضدها لتنشر بعد ذلك فروعها في
الدول الاسلاميه بيانات موحده تقول فيها
انها مطاعم مستقله فمن الذي وحد بياناتها
اما ماكدونالدز تركيا فقد اعلن عن تقديم
مليون دولار لاطفال غزه وليس لحركه حماس
فاذا كانوا يريدون المساواه بين الجلاد
والضحيه واسوه بدعم جيش اسرائيل عليهم دعم
المقاومه وعلى اثر الانتشار الواسع للحمله
قامت حسابات ماكدونالدز في عده دول عربيه
بنشر بيانات مشابهه اكدت فيها ان دور شركه
ماكدونالدز العالميه يقتصر على السماح
باستخدامه باستخدام العلامه التجاريه
محليا واشارت بعض البيانات ايضا الى الى
ان الايرادات تعود بنسبه كامله للملاك
المحليين في حين اعلنت سلسله مطاعم
ماكدونالدز في تركيا بان السلسله ستقدم
مليون دولار من المساعدات الانسانيه لدعم
اهالي غزه من ضحايا الحرب وخاصه النساء
والاطفال وكبار السن وجبات سريعه غير صحيه
من ذا الذي ما يزال ياكلها يسال متخصص صحي
ويضيف حتى لو تبرعت مطاعم الوجبات غير
الصحيه للمسجد الاقصى المبارك فمقاطع
واجبه اذا كانت صحتك وصحه ابنائك وعائلتك
تعني لك شيئا القلب هذا هل تعلم انه اذا
اكلت وجبات سريعه غير صحيه مره في الاسبوع
تزيد من احتماليه بلاء هذا القلب ومرضه
بنسبه 20% واذا اكلت من مرتين الى ثلاث
مرات في الاسبوع وجبات غير صحيه تزيد من
احتماليه بلاء هذا القلب 50% واذا تعديت
الاربع مرات في الاسبوع فاكثر 80% احتمال
اصابه هذا القلب بالمرض ويتوقع بسبب هذا
النظام اللي اصبح منتشر خاصه عند الجيل
الجديد ستنزل متوسط اعمار البشريه س الى
12 سنه هيلي روتشيلد ناشطه امريكيه تحمل
اعلام بلادها ما تصفه بتزييف الوقائع وقلب
الحقائق بحيث تصبح حماس عندها هي المعتديه
بينما هي من ترد على العدوان والاحتلال
[موسيقى]
تقول
هيلي روتشيلد يبدو اسمها يهوديا لكنها
تنتصر للحق بينما كميل شمعون لبناني يميني
متطرف برتبه نائب لم تزده صور اشلاء اطفال
غزه الا حقدا وتخلفا فيدعو مجتمعه الى عدم
التعاطف مع محرقه غزه وينشر صوره لمجموعه
من جثث الحرب اللبنانيه تحت عنوان هذه ل
يتوجع قلبه قطره دم من كل شهيد تعادل كل
فلسطين مبرزا عنوان مجزره الدامور ضد
ميليشيات مسيحيه ومناطقها التي ارتكبتها
منظمات فلسطينيه وميليشيات لبنانيه يتحالف
كميل شيمون مع بعضها اليوم في جبل لبنان
ليؤمن فوزه بالنيابه والجهل الذي يزين
شيمون اوقعه في شر حقده علق لبنانيون فنشر
صوره من ضحايا مجره صبره وشاتيلا التي
ارتكبتها من يمثل كميل شيمون من ميليشيات
مسيحيه ضد
الفلسطينيين سنلتقي حتما سنلتقي اما في
القدس واما في الجنه تلك كانت اخر عبارات
فنان المقاومه الفلسطينيه علي نسمان قبل
استشهاده اثر قصف اسرائيلي على غزه ان
الله اشترى من المؤمنين انفسهم واموالهم
بان لهم الجنه يقاتلون في سبيل الله
فيقتلون ويقتلون يقصفون بكل انواع
الطائرات بكل الاشكال بكل الالوان بكل
شراسه ولكن بفضل الله قصفهم بينزل وصواريخ
باذن الله وبفضل الله وبقووه الله سبحانه
وتعالى تخرج وتدك في معاقلهم في كل مكان
وهذا فضل الله يؤتيه لمن يشاء يؤتيه
للمجاهدين المرابطين يا مسلمين شفتوا
بعينيكم قديش غزه فرحتكم بمشاهد العزه
والفخار بعد سنوات من الذل والهوان للامه
الاسلاميه غزه التي حاصرها العالم وظلمها
وقسى عليها وقتل ابنائها لقد اعلنت غزه
النفير وارتضيت بذلك وفرحت فانفروا في
سبيل الله لا تتثاقل الى الارض لربما تكون
هذه الرساله الاخيره لربما نلتقي في
المسجد الاقصى ولربما نرتقي شهداء نسال
سبحانه وتعالى ان يكتب لنا الاجر ونستحق
بالله يا رجال انفروا انفروا والا تندموا
اخيرا ايا كان دورك في الحياه تستطيع ان
تشعل شمعه للمظلومين فكيف اذا كان
المظلومون ابناء امك وامتك الذين يكلون
اليوم قبل ان تؤكل انت في الغد مديعه
النشره الجويه في تلفزيون دوله الكويت
مريم القبندي لك التحيه اجوائنا لازالت
حاره مثل الاحداث الفلسطينيه ومعدل
درجاتها ثابت مثل صمود المقاومه في غزه
رطبه مثل رطوبه السنتنا اللي تلهج بالدعاء
لاهلنا في فلسطين اما الرياح فهي هذه
الليله على عكس موقفنا من القضيه
الفلسطينيه الثابت فهي خفيفه ومتقلب
الاتجاه فاهلا ومرحبا فيكم مشاهدينا في
نشرتنا
الجويه
ختاما قيل لشيخ المجاهدين عمر المختار ان
ايطاليا تملك طائرات حربيه ونحن لا نملك
مثلها فرد المختار هل تحلق طائراتهم فوق
العرش ام تحته قالوا تحت فقال اذا كان من
فوق العرش معنا فلا يخيفنا من تحت العرش
الى اللقاء ايش ماعمل المقاومه احنا معها
ايش ما تعمل المقاومه احنا معها احنا مع
القسام احنا مع السرايا احنا مع كل فصيل
فلسطيني بناضل من
اجلب وحسبي الله ونعم الوكيل اكتر من كده
لا عساكر كله مدني هذا مدني كله كله مدني
وين العساكر العساكر بقوهم احنا بنشوف
العساكر احنا ما بنشوف الابطال
المجاهدين
[موسيقى]
ه